it's dr. weird Wall Street where bizarre is just business as usual I'm going to kick it off here ladies and gentlemen here's a pickup line you don't hear often I have 2,000 shares of Yahoo I'm Greek and I'm a dirty old man and you look attractive that is scary does that work out you buck would that work anyway nor did it work on Marissa Meyer those are actually the exact words the exact words address to yahoo CEO marissa meyer during a Q&A sessions company's shareholder meeting yesterday she kept her cool yeah she just ignores the awkward comments and somehow moved on well that's what a CEO yeah pretty old man word of that forge ahead